même le modélisateur de plaster qu'a dit
ce matin que si les chiffres étaient
meilleurs que ce qu'il imaginait il ne
croyait plus dans la quatrième vague
qu'il a annoncé ya quinze jours et non
ça c'est vrai tout le monde est à 100 %
des gens aujourd'hui élus savent pense
que ça va bien se passer et que non que
personne encore qui continuent d'être
alarmiste mais dans une posture
idéologique
la décroissance elle est au delà de tout
ce qu'on avait imaginé donc de dire que
c'est trop tôt c'est totalement ses
passes cabine de drames en mer soir à la
loire je suis je trouve que c'est bien
mais le dr amant il ya soit faisait
quand même des choses assez raisonnable
là mais bon mon doctorat mot à vous
aimer la personne remarquable a forci
docteur lula ou amis ne la limite où les
j'appelle mon père oui oui oui
par contre on parle pas de mes couilles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais johnny ça me jette alors allez-y
alors malaisie saddam et des bas we are
one quand même on a l'impression que
gilles et monsieur division vous avez
envie que ça plante mais non mais non
c'est pas ça normalement on a
l'impression que vous n'avez pas envie
que ça fonctionne on ne peut plus comme
l'a dit très justement guillaume genton
on a envie d'y aller en bateau
ça va pas j'ai bien dit moi je suis à
l'antenne n'a pas oui j'ai entendu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dis moi pas tu trouves s'est précipité
pour à l'ouverture des terrasses ou pas
tout suivi chaque jeudi je dis pas que
c'est précipité c'est les gens qui se
sont précipités à bien gens se
précipiter son côté des hôtes il soit
quelques mètres à sa tête je trouve je
sois du mans parce qu'au delà des jeunes
c'est de combien de temps je suis co
vide le set du gic éventuellement il
faut agiter les rapprochements et là ils
sont tous assis à côté des deux manches
et les reds je trouve ça complètement
non l arabe risque étudié mon père
d'assas votre père louis-marie c'est
pour dire qu'il faut il faut comme ça il
faut quand même tempérer les choses
en fait dans cette maladie on sait rien
et en fait tout le monde c'est comme
s'il avait quelque chose alors il faut
arrêter un peu
[Applaudissements]
je me dis toi même comme c'est donc des
gens intelligents peuvent faire des
abruzzes c'est trop attaché un truc de
fou où il fabrique surtout des
camemberts tension c'est mon père
qu'elle descend ya raccrocher lundi marc
pado qu'est son répondeur docteur
hanouna du coup les contaminations
extérieures même l' agence américaine
dit que ça n'existe quasiment pas et se
sont même excusé d'avoir surestimé le
risque de contamination extérieure je
pense que les français peuvent profiter
en terrasse en revanche à l'intérieur
qu'ils fassent attention donc pas
d'après soirée d'after en intérieur
après ça s'appelle mention spéciale
gilles verdez à propos du masque à
l'extérieur c'est-à-dire vous souvenez
quand effectivement gilbert gaz ici
sorte un rapport de cas d une médecine
de 2020 c'est ce dernier qui les lui et
où le seul où effectivement et vous
expliquer que les contaminations à
l'extérieur était importante et que le
masque à l'extérieur était une
précaution deux suivants nécessaire et
où je disais ici qu'il n'y avait pas de
contamination extérieure et que de
masquer à l'extérieur n'avaient
absolument aucun fondement
il aura encore fallu un peu plus
longtemps que d'habitude c'est à dire un
mois et demi pour que j'ai raison et
vous vous êtes toujours fait ça c'est
vrai fabrice d'être en avance mais ça
vous fait penser que c'est prématuré ou
pas mais oui moi ce que je pense et je
suis extrêmement je suis ému aux larmes
devant dans cette générosité de notre
président de la république qui nous
restitue les terrasses mon dieu que
c'est beau vous avez vu un peu tout à
l'heure c'était motion en terrasse que
vous avez eue c'est magnifique quoi ces
français qui sont en terrasse qui ont la
liberté
merci monsieur le président alors
évidemment il ya une autre façon de voir
les choses c'est que cette liberté elle
m'appartient et que ça fait juste un an
qu'on me la piquer mais après donc si
maintenant il faut que je remercie en
plus et ceux qui m'ont pris ma liberté
de me la rendre
bon bah super ont pu faire ça
je trouve ça délirant très franchement
et je suis assez d'accord avec votre
père c'est très prématuré les gens vont
se rapprocher
vous savez trés mais vous savez très
bien si chez nous et la voiture et là ce
que c'est pas d'accord avec le bras vous
d'accord vous vous êtes pour la liberté
retrouvée mais non parce que les gens
ils vont rester à cinq à six à dix avant
fin devant prolonger la soirée c'est
dangereux cyril faisant attention
attention